all right so I saw the videos and you
know I try to pick something that is
going to have the greatest effect on you
um and what I'm going to pick for this
time things are looking good I saw a lot
of good stuff but the thing that I think
will have the greatest effect on you is
to remove tension from your body okay um
we have we're struggling with that here
too there's absolutely no way I can do
the spiritual components or the
energetic components
with tension in my body
okay um right now we're using tension we
don't realize it we're using tension out
of
fear and fear makes us want to seek
control and we justify it because if we
don't do it then our fear is going to
make it come true whatever we're trying
to avoid but you want to just let go of
all that okay so uh make a semicircle
here you're going to do what I'm saying
to the camera okay okay all right uh
just the way that
our most Americans work we're I'm going
to teach it for that okay but normally
if you would here we work on you okay
but uh let us start with putting our
feet somewhere between under our hips
never go more narrow than than your
hips and uh never go wider than your
shoulders okay okay what we don't want
is an angle that makes my arches cave in
like that would be incorrect or an angle
that would make my uh knife edge be
weighted okay so I want my
foot so that I have skeletal alignment
on my legs up through my pelvis
okay and I want to spread the
metatarsals those are the bones on my
feet okay at no point do I want to grip
the mat nor have my foot
roll let it be
flat have your feet straight the metric
I'm going to give you is your middle toe
your middle toe should be straight on
most Americans this feels straight this
is not straight this is a product of
tension from the mid the lower back down
the back of the legs and your body is
seeking slack
okay middle toe perfectly straight for
you that might feel like you're pitching
toe okay that's all a sign that you
you're jacked up okay so once I get that
skeletal
alignment what I'm going to try to do is
use the skeletal alignment and bear with
me this is all Poetics I'm going to use
the skeletal alignment to generate an
upward and energy such that my soft
tissue my muscles Etc can generate a
descending energy okay that's what I'm
going to try to do and so I do that by
just first relaxing and
releasing start with the
shoulders Let Them Fall
Down Let Your Arms go so here I would
not be relaxed you see cuz my my arms
are being held up just let them all go
don't have anything magical in mind or
anything except for the skeletal
alignment is Lifting me up and my
shoulders currently are dropping
down
relax once you feel like you know what
not they're not going to drop any more
than that okay all right then what I
want you to do is take your shoulder
blades your scapula and move your
scapula around don't move your Del toys
around move your scapula make circles
going back with the
scapula
okay so we'll try that first
exercise so don't force them back just
move in circles letting everything hang
don't go I can go back
more
okay so your body is perfectly upright
except for your shoulders which makes no
sense okay if your body was relaxed and
hanging when you move your shoulders
back you're going to see the movement in
your frame so film I start
out I'm going to move my shoulder blades
and you can see things already mve
shoulders Rock back the knees on their
own they bed more and you start going
you start seeing that things are
moving for me to be straight and move
the shoulder blades only to stay
straight I have tension in my legs
okay be careful though of the ego
tripartite mind because you're like I I
want movement I didn't I didn't generate
that movement I'm just hanging out
and I'm letting this do this to my body
but I'm
not you see that that's forcing it okay
I'm just moving this these shoulder
blades always releasing
tension you can go slow doesn't
matter but you can still see the
movement in the pelvis and the knees
okay all right try it again okay next
one everything's the
same I want you to take this hotle
band okay and you're going to make a
circle with
it
Circle one way everything stays relaxed
my shoulder blades are loose everything
is hanging okay I'm not moving my hips
I'm moving that thing in a circle so you
should
feel uh a passive stretching or opening
or
releasing probably like I feel it from
here to here you see on that movement
and I come
around
opening and then I feel the other one on
the other side and I come around okay
but all I'm I'm not
going I'm just moving it and letting
gravity pull those tissues down
as the skeleton is making things go up
okay try that one do One
Direction and then the other
way don't let your your spine cave
though the spine doesn't
cave you're just moving the the
band don't hunch there so move in this
part so this part up here stays straight
you see I go here it stay straight up
there you see it doesn't go like this do
you see that so likewise when I go
forward when I come around this way the
top part stays where it is it doesn't go
like that can you guys see that so I'm
not
going this way I just move in this part
okay if you want to do something with
your hands you come
around
change
stretch you can
alternate my H is moving my H Band is
moving my
arms I'm not moving my position okay try
it don't let your your feet
roll feet roll in tension in your lower
legs don't have don't grab with your
toes is
fear middle toe is
straight your body's looking for
slack middle toe is straight your heels
there you go don't move your arms your
hota moves your
arms you got to get them
up that's moving your
arms move that band make a full circle
with the band it's got to come
forward got to come
forward all the way around come on on
let's
go my qua here this seam right here okay
I'm going to
bend this knee I'm going to take this
knee to the Y Line which we already know
his knees to toe okay but I take it
there and then I do the other one
you can see I I have to go up and down
as well as turn do you see that okay and
then I want my arms to just be loose and
I'm moving my
quad and my arms are just Coincidence of
that
movement
okay try that one Bend one knee then
bend the other
knee there's certain
rules the Y phase is the knee goes to
the toe
line got it and I can never
violate the foot knee hip line no do you
see that my knee is not in alignment
with my
foot it has to stay in alignment so when
I go and I shift keeps
alignment no that's going to injure me
and I do the other side
alignment
alignment it takes some in
attention that you're not doing
that so I'm over here I shift my weight
we over
there shift my weight over
here
wrong okay try it again next one is our
vertebrae okay we'll do it this way so
I'm going to shift both knees to the Y
Line you see back to my Tae okay and
that starts a
wave up my spine that I word okay so I'm
trying to make each
vertebrae way okay way is what I'm
trying to do so
vom you could take breaks between as you
do it but this is not it you see right
okay that looks weird
huh okay and be careful though often
times beginners they go here like this I
don't want that kink in my neck okay so
my neck only goes from the neutral
position forward so knees to Young that
begins it you see neutral position at
the end but if you look it's forward
chin down as it comes up
okay okay try it move your move your
neck chin down chin
neutral you can feel that coordination
issue there
right don't go too far back don't don't
exaggerate anything the skeleton going
up is all we're using to generate the
stretch the tissue going down we're not
forcing
anything bring your knees forward to the
Yang line at the
beginning
breathe constricted breath is
tension
try to get every vertebrae to
[Music]
roll need a little more movement there a
y next one on the pelvis okay this part
here so I'm going to tilt it up making
figure eight be care careful on this one
it's very common that you violate the
foot rule okay so I have my qual but I'm
going to tilt my pelvis on that do you
see how I did that so the last drill I
didn't okay on this drill oh I am going
to tilt it I tilt the PBS so I'm making
figure eight it's almost like I'm rowing
backwards rowing backwards do you see
that can you is it visible or no okay so
I'm roll backwards and then when you're
ready you'll go fig F A the other way
figure a the other way without turning
the knee in okay try figure eight
forward down back up forward
down they're trading
sides then you reverse it so if you were
kaying you're going backwards and you're
kayaking I don't know if you go that way
and kayaking I guess you do okay
okay it's not a
circle it's not a circle
look and I I want you to just kind of
bring your attention or your
observation bring your
observation inside this part of your
body okay so you'll feel for it you'll
have this kind of top of the sternum
there's a bone there just above it
you'll start to feel that trachea in
there if I push into it you can hear it
change my voice okay inside behind that
surface of that trachea that's where I
want to put my observation okay and I'm
going to really try
to release that part just like I
released my shoulders at the beginning
let them hang okay I'm going to first
release this part I'm going to start
like I did before but now I'm going to
bring that attention that observation
here let that part drop as
well I don't pull anything down I don't
do anything just keep trying to relax
release any flexion release any
flexion and by releasing the flexion I
let go of that spot and then I'm
observant of what happens when I let go
that spot okay try
that okay now we'll go into
SE same
thing I'm going to stack my skeletal
tissue in this case it's going to be my
pelvis and my spine and my head okay
we'll just have our hands down here by
our
knees you're going to have to figure out
what is the pelvis angle that Stacks the
spine on the pel on the uh pelvis okay
so for example if I'm here like this I
tilt my pelvis down
I my spine is not stacked on it do you
guys see that okay so that creates
pressure somewhere around
here you don't want that so I'll change
my
pelvis till that pressure goes
away until my
spine can just do nothing because it's
stacked on
itself once I hit that spot to do
exactly what I've been doing you may
have tension in your thighs and your
knees and your
ankles that you have to release you
don't have to stretch it you have to
release
it so I'm letting go of all
that and when I'm ready I take that last
drill bring my observation there
and I release
it again some metrics that you can use I
always hesitant to give metrics but if
you pay attention I gave you several
already this
hurts that hurts I I feel that that's
not right okay so I move it till it
stops hurting and it it takes no energy
to stay
upright this might hurt this might hurt
you see let go of tension and the pain
will go
away you you'll see as you're trying
this it will be a matter of Faith you
won't believe me at first but
therein is the ceiling of your training
you can't let go of this let's say
you're here like this you can release
release release release and you'll get
there just keep releasing the
tension okay so another metric what is
it doesn't hurt
anymore another metric once you drop
this is you'll watch what'll happen here
I don't do it it but I start to expand
here almost like today's standards
embarrassingly okay so I'm doing my
thing get myself in
position scan my legs for tension
release I get onto that
throat let it all
drop
when you first start this spot will
go between flexing and releasing flexing
and releasing releasing depending on
whether you're inhaling or exhaling if
only because you brought your conscious
mind to the act or you brought your
conscious mind to whoa what happened
don't do that just stick with the drill
I gave you release tension release
tension release tension and only observe
only observe what happens when you
release tension don't try to make your
stomach swir out okay that's not what
we're doing okay all right and what ends
up happening is you'll do what we call
abdominal breathing of course all
breathing is abdominal because your
diaphragm moves your lower torso what we
mean is that your breath is down
here not breath but it'll it'll we have
new people it's a start okay it's yongi
yongi fills up down here drops down in
the body okay all right let's try it
here we go remember to stack your spine
so don't Lean Back Lean a little
forward come a little
forward stack your spine but don't
concave your spine stacking your spine
is going to put everything straight on
every vertebrae straight on it you you
tend to loosen each vertebrae when
you're trying to relax okay
that's why I say
release so stack the spine stack the
spine more it's not
stacked leave the spine
stacked and now let every other tissue
drop but not the
spine
your pelvis should begin also to settle
between your legs not sit on top of your
legs so
when I'm tight I'm on top of my pelvis
but if you pay
attention I'm going to sink into
it that'll drop through my legs because
my femur aren't holding it up anymore so
it should drop so I'm down
here
so if you watch Tristan come on
over and when he pushes
down okay here
is a catalyst for tension he pushes and
I go whoa hold it still you see that
he's a psychological Catalyst that
triggers me into
tension so I did all my warm-ups I did
all my
stretches I should be sunk and so when
he goes to push I now have a chance to
get even more released because of the
Catalyst wants me to do the
opposite so I do doing everything
exactly the same that I was doing before
I'm paying attention to here my chin is
slightly down this is very important not
to do this okay so your chin is slightly
down and slightly back because to stack
my vertebrae I can't do that do you see
that so it has to go slightly
back I can't be up here cuz I'm leaning
back do you see that so I'm over here
and then as he's pushing I just keep
releasing and releasing anything that
was flexed I keep my mind
here so uh let let's see you might have
to stand up
Kim and Taylor come on over on this
side so in normal assumption this is a
tricep
extension do you guys understand that
okay and uh again almost embarrassingly
I do have tricep muscles okay but you're
going to watch and I'm going to get
myself in that position where I can be
totally released and
relaxed and then Taylor you can just
kind of push in these all these mushy
places especially go to the other side
where I put you camera the tricep is
embarrassingly
squishy you see that what it say like
see I do have muscles okay but I'm not
using them and then if you come
up and you poke around it's not a bench
press exercise again I do have pecs but
they're surprisingly
mushy
okay got it
okay that is difficult because this is a
huge Catalyst for us but it starts in
the other stuff okay if we look at the
other drills I'm telling you to relax
and you're
like okay so but it is still that's you
have to do those drills to relax you
have to be able to sit in Sea to relax
and then you could do this so we're
going to do this drill anyways even
though it might be above most of us here
but the mechanics is the same okay got
it so if you don't it doesn't look like
he's pushing because I don't look like
I'm pushing back at him but he's driving
hard he could stand up and you should he
should be able to knock me over but he
he can't and again I am
super
relaxed
okay you'll feel that when I throw you
okay Brian when I throw you you'll go
what the hell was that okay but it
starts from there okay all
right
okay so again just it's about starting
out these are beginner drills okay so uh
it's very
important the way I position your body
okay and so you have to have the chin
slightly down you can't have the chin
up you can't have the chin forward
either okay so it kind of goes back do
you see that okay and then relax
everything but I can't relax my
spine the skeletal system H is going to
be stacked on each other
okay and then I told you is seated
release the ankle
release the knees the knees the back of
the knees are huge emotional centers as
well as the lower leg which means they
are susceptible to habitual unconscious
tension okay and then look for the
pelvis to
drop in between the
legs
okay and then uh I just want to point
out that it's a beginner skeletal
alignment I don't want you to to become
a
materialist and think it's about that
structure it's not okay so here he is
he's I I have all that and then a lot of
people will go oh it's
biomechanical okay but you once you
understand what's going on you you could
do whatever you could compromise the
spine and he still can't push me over
and I'm just as relaxed okay you could
do anything weird and he still can't do
it okay but if you pay
attention remember I said the metric is
that this thing starts to expand okay so
you're going to come behind me when I
got all mushy on the
arms we're going to ride our Harley
together okay and you're here don't
don't compress me just feel okay and
then as he goes and I'll get myself into
it you should already start feeling cuz
I can feel
it push harder you'll feel it expand
more and the harder he goes the more I
release and now watch me keep it on
there you see how big I got I'll change
my posture but you'll see that that part
doesn't change you see so I'm going
around that part there that that part
will not change as long as I'm doing my
thing okay you can stand up so you have
more Mobility
okay it goes so no matter what I'm doing
that part stays
exactly that
same size and but I'm relaxed but that
part has you can now try try to squeeze
it and you'll feel like w that thing is
not squeezable nowhere near as mushy as
that
tricep you see that
okay it's crazy okay all right the last
thing I would like you to do is to bring
your feet into your
training
um and if you don't mind come from the
back of
me uh same thing and here is another
thing let me just stay there you can
stay there pain is another Catalyst okay
I mentioned it if you release the pain
that you think is in your ankles and
your knees and your hips it'll go away
if you truly are releasing okay pain is
a an emotional manifestation if you
release the pain will go away again it's
up it's your faith if you believe that
or not okay uh but in the same way that
the UK is a catalyst to trigger a
flexion I use pain the same way okay I
use pain to and then I practice the
releasing from the pain and the pain
goes away so I do want you in this case
to do an active stretch but you're doing
it from the point of view of release to
make the pain stop
okay so here I am in
Kiza okay and again I'll settle in Kiza
just like I did in cesa so I'll stack my
spine exactly like I was and I'll start
generating huge amount of
downward weight on those balls of my
feet on the toes do you see that okay
and then I'm going to start going
forward and it's going to start hurting
and I just release that release it you
might not be able to go this fast okay
but you will release it release it
release it release it I keep releasing
it releasing it releasing it releasing
it
until I am now in
CA say
SLA and I'll settle
there
and that pain will go away I don't even
notice what I'm in
okay um because a
balance is hugely affected by tension
from the toes up to that emotional
Center behind the knee so balancing your
Technique is is is when you don't have
it when you don't feel it it's usually
you have habitual unconscious flexion
from the back of the knees all the way
to the tips of the toes and you just
can't feel it
okay um and more importantly that
habitual tension which it shows up in a
lack of balance but that tension does
not allow the Yang energy to bounce down
to the ground gets blocked at the lower
at the back of the knee and you lose
your balance and you won't actually ever
get the Earth Chi that bounc back up so
you have to lose the tension and I saw a
lot of tension in your feet and your
lower legs so this is a uh another
releasing drill that you should start
adopting okay all right we're all going
to try that now